you know marlins is the he says the mo i
mean he is the king of random [ __ ] oh
yeah i just there's only one of no
there's only one harlem williams i mean
he's like sir have you ever uh made love
to a dairy queen uh blizzard on a hot
saturday night
uh no well you're not living or you will
yeah yeah he just says these random
things man ma'am if you could look away
i'm doing a show please
yeah sorry i don't like your [ __ ]
eyes can you go to sleep i like your
eyes did he ever say that oh yeah i
don't like your eyes
for about a year and a half and i just
saw him just do some like
phenomenal [ __ ] man that was like
next level and it just made me go oh i
gotta i want to do that i want to get
good he was just like you got to listen
you got to trust to build a moment
gather some info and then just about
doing it getting reps of like trusting
yourself to
think of the funny thing and then say it
and then not you know what i'm saying
because when i would first start doing
crowd work i wouldn't listen
so i'd be you know talking like this and
then like oh where are you from or or
what you know how long have you guys
been together and then i'd be like [ __ ]
20 seconds went by and there were no
laughs i'm thinking that not listening
to what they're just saying so then they
stopped talking and i'm like yeah you
guys look like you're not gonna make it
you know you just say something to panic
to fill in the time and then you're like
and everyone's like all right [ __ ] that
was weird
um so you learned
have you ever gotten the silence how
long did you bomb how many times have
you bombed i mean how many times have
you rose and bombed come on
in your life how many nice a lot uh oh
yeah getting going i mean look i did
plays you know all through high school
and college so i was always comfy on
stage and that's just the writing so um
uh
yeah i mean
yeah probably
once you're getting up there you go i
you know in this the sets are six seven
eight minutes you're like
i can get laughs throughout this but
yeah am i gonna crush for eight minutes
no that takes a minute to be [ __ ]
great but then i went to this random
comedy festival in calgary somehow like
when i was three years in and i remember
having like a string of good shows and i
was like all right [ __ ] here we go and
then getting a little too ahead of
myself and then coming back to la and
being like oh no that was just that was
just out there and like for whatever
reason like that was then translate yeah
and uh
but that you get better i always say too
it's like you know you you always want
to get off stage with a positive and a
negative i immediately try to not beat
myself up over it which i you know
do a lot but i sorry joe all right what
was what was great here that was cool
and what's something to work on not even
like good and bad but what's something
to work on what could i my fiance always
gives me [ __ ] about that because i'll
literally get home and go oh man
i should have said that in that moment
and said for that joke or when this
crowdwork thing happened i was like what
ah should have said that when he said
that she's like the moment's over it's
done yeah she's like stop doing that i
go no no i'm not upset or beating myself
up this is how i also like get like
process reviewing the game tape you know
what i'm saying but it's like i see
because i record my sets and sometimes i
listen and sometimes i don't but if i
can immediately just
you know i have a weird way to if i'm
saying that like oh i could have said
that okay
okay cool i can like somehow uh
uh pocket that for the next time